mais bon soit merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation
on vient d'entendre intériste racisme
qui vous dit que vous êtes trompés vous
parle même de boucs émissaires alors
pourquoi vous choisi de quitter cette
association
oui je sais pas ce qu'on a voulu dire
comme par cette histoire de bouc
émissaire je j'ai quitté cette
association je précise que bien entendu
j'étais tout à fait je reste d'accord
sur l'objectif la lutte contre le
racisme mais je trouve que les moyens
employés ont été dans cette affaire où
il existe en use je dirais ne tenant pas
compte de ce qui est fondamental pour
moi dans cette affaire c'est-à-dire la
défense de la dignité de la femme et
j'ai attendu
j'ai démissionné hier soir il ya une
guerre action forcément madame boudjema
entre autres qui parlent de bouc
émissaire que moi je prendrais dans la
personne des jeunes musulmanes les
jeunes musulmanes apprécieront d'un même
mais je n'ai pas trouvé encore une seule
réaction où on parle enfin de la femme
car tu m'aimes c'est tchador c'est pour
la femme c'est pas pour l'homme qu'est
ce qu'il représente pour vous cette
chaleur madame et politique il faut le
refuser pour cette raison pas seulement
il est d'abord un emblème religieux et
ça c'est une atteinte à la laïcité mais
pas dans le sens un peu ordinaire la
laïcité quand il s'agit de l'école et
c'est pour ça que c'était la lutte de
sos racisme c'est que l'on laisse au
vestiaire
non seulement ces couteaux mais c'est
croise et tchador en tout cas c'est
emblème religieux parce qu'il faut
arriver avec une certaine disponibilité
alors il faut faire comment sa
différence et pour dire comment le monde
antique excusez moi il faut faire comme
en belgique il faut interdire ces à ses
élèves de le fréquenter l'établissement
c'est la presse et la proposition est la
position de choisir parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on essaie de faire
croire depuis que cette affaire comment
bouc émissaire on vient de vivre mais
vous allez les exclure de
l'établissement est pas du tout la loi
française et geslin sur le sur
l'enseignement rend l'enseignement
obligatoire de 6 ans à 16 ans et
l'étranger soumis également cette loi à
condition bien sûr qu'ils soient en
situation régulière donc c'est très
simple pour venir à l'école et je crois
qu'on les soulagera énormément ses
fillettes
car personne ne peut croire une seconde
qu elles se sont réveillées comme des
jeanne d'arc de l'islam en se disant là
il faut le tchador
elles sont sous le joug patriarcale du
pater familias les tribus arabes qui est
fort et je sais de quoi je parle quand
je suis d'origine tunisienne et elles se
sont réveillées aussi sous le joug de
ses pairs manipulés par des parts des
délits des fanatiques religieux
musulmans alors le tchador ça n'est pas
seulement religieux ces politiques ne
nous y trompons guerre et c'est surtout
et c'est là que je veux en vie
c'est tout même le symbole de la
soumission et de l'infériorisation de la
femme et je m'étonne que sos racisme
c'est très bien que ce soit une femme
qui en ai parlé mais je n'ai pas encore
entendu dire que les femmes avaient
besoin droit à leur dignité qu'elle
n'avait pas à se cacher qu'elle n'avait
pas accepté la polygamie que n'avait pas
à accepter d'être répudiée
et vous savez ce qui est frappant vous
parlez de l'âme de la belgique s'est
tout de même bien la preuve car on m'a
appelé belgique pour me dire non
seulement ça c'est fait mais ça s'est
fait avec comme argumentation en france
on l'accepté pourquoi pas à bruxelles
mais en tunisie où donc suis originaire
attendait et on a remis en vigueur
aujourd'hui on a rappelé la circulaire
qui interdit le port du tchador
alors c'est un peu ce qu'ils disent
c'est ici que l'on va l'accueillir
c'est le service qu'on rend à ces jeunes
femmes qui veulent se bat merci madame
merci pour cette explication je rappelle
donc que vous avez démissionné de
l'association sos racisme
[Musique]